this is the key to the tick tock
testimony that people don't seem to be
picking up on the CEO wrote We are
committed to providing a safe secure
platform that Fosters an inclusive space
for our amazing diverse communities to
call home it's a shame today's
conversation felt rooted in xenophobia
thank you to our employees who worked
tirelessly to protect our platform and
Community this wasn't just a big flop
accident oh my gosh what was Tick Tock
thinking showing up to Capitol Hill oh
no Tick Tock knew the questions that
they were going to be asked Tick Tock
knew that the answers were going to be a
little bit awkward that was baked in but
what Tick Tock has done and I suspect
this will be successful is they've now
made an effort to reframe the debate
about banning tick tock